le frelon asiatique a été repéré dans le
sud de la france en 2004 une reine
serait arrivé par cargo en provenance de
shanghai son origine native depuis la
coloniser 70% du territoire français on
le trouve aussi en espagne au portugal
en italie en belgique et en allemagne
prédateur il a un impact sur la
biodiversité et crée aussi des problèmes
économiques
on connaît le haut niveau du secteur
apicole le problème que représente le
pôle asiatique sur le fonctionnement et
la survie des colonies d'abeilles
donc ce secteur est très touchée mais
probablement également d'autres secteurs
par exemple tout ce qui est là gage
l'entretien des parcs et jardins mais
également des professionnels du commerce
sur des marchés par exemple en plein air
sauf que le frelon asiatique court
peut-être à sa perte à cause de son
faible patrimoine génétique issu d'une
seule reine en clair quand une reine
n'est pas fécondé elle produit des oeufs
à pleaux ide qui donne des mâles quand
elle est fécondé elle produit des oeufs
diploïdes qui donnent habituellement des
femelles
oui mais des chercheurs de l'irb y ont
observé des mac diploïdes des effets
condé mais pauvre génétiquement et les
mâles chez le frelon ne font rien sont
un fardeau pour la colonie et nuisent à
son développement ils ont montré qu'en
chine on avait une diversité génétique
ce normal dans une population native
mais la population française est très
homogène au niveau génétique
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont pu montrer que
l'introduction de cette espèce en france
est le fait d'un très faible nombre
d'individus voire même une seule reine
ce qui fait que la population française
elle est très homogène au niveau
génétique et du coup par rapport à ce
résultat on pouvait s'attendre à
observer des mâles diploïdes au bout
d'un certain temps
effectivement c'est ce qu'on a observé
nous à partir de 2012 alors pourquoi
l'écolo nid de frelons asiatiques
semblent toujours en expansion
c'est peut-être que les reines ont
adopté une stratégie s'accoupler avec
plusieurs mâles car chez le frelon qui
dit diversité de spermatozoïdes dix
naissances deux femelles et préservation
de l'espèce
cela fera l'objet de nouvelles
recherches au sein de l'unité
tourangelle